i i would say i mean certainly over 15
years
there is the uh i don't need to see him
right now
sure i'm not knocking on his door the
first thing in the morning
uh i know i'm gonna see him in 10
minutes anyway
right i'm sure he feels the same way i
didn't sleep i missed you
you know uh but i will say for
the the massive majority of our time
we are buddies hanging out and it's it
you know we have
i i think i think it's been one of the
greatest successes of the show is
is how uh how well and how consistently
we've gotten along both on and off set
and misha are you tighter with one of
them or they just both equally kind of
your guys no he kind of rounds he kind
of it's interesting he
he adds this perfect like extra extra
trifecta layer you know and and it's
uh i think we all get along and all have
you know i've got
i've got my friendship with misha and
jared's got his friendship with misha
and then jared and i have our friendship
and but then also we have this kind of
triangular
uh uh relationship as well that just
works it
it works on a public forum and it works
in a private form
who's got the shortest fuse on set if
someone's going to snap
who's going to be oh jerry do you guys
enjoy watching this like do you look at
each other like no there he goes
i have literally fire started and lit
his fuse
so many times just to sit back and go
what is it you do is it things like
because a welling would
would have he would do that to me and he
would also
be in a you know i know that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he would sometimes he'd be in a pissy
mood and for some reason if i came in
and i was
a pissy mood it'd make him happy he
would suddenly get out of the bad mood
he'd love seeing me lose it
what are we doing why are we filming
they told me to come and sit in a rush
to sit him late
and then well he'll turn around while
he's got his hand up to his face he's
like
[ __ ] like you know but i would say um
generally jared and i's uh frustrations
are very much in line
so if something is not working or
something is just seems off or it's
it's it's frustrating
i i will either quickly bring it to his
attention or he'll quickly bring it to
mind
and then uh depending on the
the severity of it i also know where
this could go
either he's gonna get wound up and
head you're gonna roll uh or
i'm gonna defuse the situation and and
cooler heads will prevail and
and we'll we'll you know we'll move past
it
um very rarely do i get tuned up and
have to
or do i get wound up and have to tune
somebody what's an incident where
jared would have probably been like wow
jensen's going off
like jensen never he's even killed he
never loses it what's the one moment
i could see it you remember it no well
i'm trying to think there's there's been
a few over the years where
where he so he surprisingly uh just got
to sit back and watch me go
although you know he's he is the type
and he's the
good the good friend that he is you know
he he
he's right there behind me to throw in
the insults as well so
uh uh there there have been a few we
we've had some some guard changes in
certain positions over the years and
those people in in their authoritative
position would maybe treat people that
we have a very close relationship with
uh that are underneath their position
and we would start hearing that they
were getting treated less than they
should
and so we would then have to you know
put on our our producer hats that we
actually don't own
and uh and go and go and go set some
people straight